love
you I had it with all of you all right
that's
good it's over there before you come
back down here and drive me crazy take
everything check everything you're worse
than
George I'm worse than George come on
Terry come on come just get the phone
and come all right do you want me to
call you don't get us started please let
her go upstairs
already
I almost got rid of her now you want to
play phone
games I thought you looking for it
you're another genius I'm trying
to get rid of these people and you keep
there you what doctor did you go to what
he just had a foot in the car
why are you bothering these
people because I don't know you're
trying to be helpful well listen you
want to be helpful join a Convent go to
and dig trenches or something that's
what you do if you want to be helpful
but some of these people just mind your
business what do you care in reality I'm
saying what you scratching your nose for
you I must be Jesus Christ what's going
on brother already it's good to see
buddy you know everything else is good
except for my
ankle so do you want to tell the
story no no no I want to get the party
started let's flow with the you know
let's do this get the music
out let's get the yelling and screaming
let's stab people it's Tuesday
morning let's go what's happening you
Savages it's Tuesday the 14th of
November listen if you want to get it on
you're gonna have to get it up all right
and blue Sho can help you Joey it's a
Tuesday morning why are you starting
with this because listen it's the
holiday season you want to get Santa
Claus ready to give out yum yums listen
for you people who don't know blue Chu
it's an online service that delivers ED
medication right to your door it's got
the same active ingredients as Viagra
Calis and Levitra at a fraction of the
cost how much do I love blueo
tremendously and I'll tell you why it's
easy to sign up it's convenient they
come individually wrapped in a little
package you put on your wallet by the
time you use it it's probably melted but
who cares you swallow that thing and
within
minutes oh yeah like I said you're like
Santa Claus giving out yum yums I love
blueo because it's easy to get started
sign up at blu.com
and tell one of that licensed medical
providers about what's going on with you
and once you get approved bang you get
your prescription a few days just like
that everything is done online so you
can you skip all the waiting in the
doctor's office and stupid questions and
insurance information da da da da da da
we don't need that in our lives and it
gets delivered right to your door nobody
knows nothing not even the mailman blue
chw wants to help you have better sex is
the holiday season who doesn't want a
dick sling dick with three hands
discover your options at
blue.com chew it and then do it yeah as
a special deal for checking listeners
get ready for this try blue CH free Joey
it's Tuesday morning don't bust my chop
it's for free Jack blue true free when
you use promo code Joey Joe y at
checkout just pay the fin that's $5 for
shipping that's it that's blu.com promo
code Joey to receive your first month
free and nobody knows nothing not even
the mailman all right you ready for this
one
Babble I love these
people stop wasting your time other
language learning apps are basically
just games and teach you nothing if you
want to be fluent in a new language you
got to use Babel ba BB L why number one
you should know another language it just
makes you smarter it makes you more
analytical you'll learn and Babel's
10-minute lessons will get you speaking
a whole new language and just three
weeks you too could be singing some many
Benny morray it's tremendous it's easy
to sign up babbles tips and tools are
accessible approachable and delivered
with conversation Based Teaching that's
tremendous right there studies even show
that you in Babble for 15 hours is
equivalent to an entire semester of
college language course here's a special
limited time deal for you guys the
checkin listeners we're going to get you
started right now get ready for this 55%
off not half off 55% off your Babel
subscription but only for checkin
listeners when you download Babble and
use code Joey Joe y That's 55 who gives
you 55% off babel.com
jooy spell
Babel
babbel.com
joeey rules and restrictions apply and
oh my God look at this guess who came
out for the holidays liquid IV oh my God
guys you got to taste the sugar-free
Peach forget about it it's beginning to
look a lot like Christmas you're going
to be putting food in your mouth between
the travel and hosting the family dinner
and shopping guess what you got to keep
yourself hydrated with liquid IV with
three times the electrolytes of leading
sports drinks plus eight vitamins and
nutrients for everyday Wellness no
matter when you're up to it liquid IV
will keep you hydrated liquid IV
hydrates twice as fast as regular water
alone twice as fast liquid IV is now
available in three sugar-free flavors
you ready white peach tremendous green
grape tremendous lemon lime I haven't
tried it yet with no artificial
Sweetness in it just got an amazing
flavor without the gross bitter after
taste listen you guys know me I love
liquid IV I drink it every day in the
morning to get the party started to take
the maluia juice out of my head and it
works perfectly you know why it's
glutenfree dairy free soy free it has no
GMOs liquid IV is an amazing addition to
your hydration routine whatever it may
be so do me a favor grab your liquid IV
hydration multiplier sugarfree in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20%
off when you go to liquid i.com and use
promo code Joey listen this is 20% off
liquid IV trust me this is gold that's
20% off anything you order when you shop
better hydration today use promo code
Joey at liquid
i.com enough enough Joey hit me with the
show baby boy turn up your TVs run for
your lives it's over they didn't put you
on this planet just to give up if Uncle
Joey could do it I can rule the world
actually you got to be thinking welcome
back
[Music]
to
Illinois it's Tuesday morning let's do
this for these people it's getting
to the tough time of the year
thanksgiving's coming then the
holidays are coming people G to be
jumping up and down then one of these
MOS is gonna drop a bomb you know some
somewhere there's going to be something
like on December 12th isn't there
another Jewish holiday coming up there h
coming up what is
that I'm a bad you I don't know it's
coming up soon though it's like early
December oh early September I'm talking
about what's coming up now in no no I
said early December all right so right
there they're gonna try to mess up
anuka it would be the
obvious it would be the obvious listen
I'm no War guy on CNN what do I
know I'm a F you know what I'm
saying drop that mic B you know what I'm
talking about I don't know nothing
I'm just giving you my opinion this you
know anything could happen right
now so before you go spending for that
stereo putting on layway you better hold
on to that Gus to the
24th God they still got it when you get
down there at 601 looking like you lost
your puppy and tell me they still
got the stereo my girl really want
it I'll take the floor model it's
missing a needle I don't give a
I'll sing tonight and get the needle in
two
days like I like Christmas but I hate
about Christmas like I sto even
going to Super I stopped going to
supermarkets after December first
because I can't because it just I don't
know I don't like that
Christmas when you walk into
aore walking around like R what's that
what are you talking about you don't
like the radio the radio it's always
pre-programmed
mishmash that they play a weekly rapb
over the
holidays so as soon as you walk in there
it's Christmas Christmas Christmas and
then it's
bing bing 30% off 80%
off you now go
yourself all right thanks I needed that
my world yeah so it's kind of
weird how I don't know I hate that time
I love Christmas like I love the
week before Christmas when it's really
just over it's okay to be like
you have a legal license to be a
Momo you get drunk you could do this you
could do that you know
but you know who gives a I don't
know what I'm talking about I smoked
that weed
he said you like before Christmas yeah
the week before Christmas it's all right
to be a half a truits you could
walk around drink you know fall on the
floor that's a but I'm Gonna Give You
advisory right now okay and it happened
me two years in a
row after the 15th this year
don't sign up for
dick don't sign up an open mic be real
prepared don't get too close to people
because people forget CO's still out
there and with your luck you're going to
get it on the 23rd and then you can't go
to Grandma's and eat lasagna whatever
other the she's eating you know
what I'm saying like I I didn't get it
last year but the year before I
got and I think the year before I got
ruined uh something happened to
Christmas before so the the planes scare
me a little bit that's like the only
time I'm like o because I've always I've
gone on planes both
times it's not even the plane it's the
it's not even the plane as much as the
the
airport I think it's just a lot of
people at the airport you're in small
spaces for a long but who gives a
we all know that if you're GNA fly out
the holidays bring a helmet and bring
Vaseline that's all I got to tell you
you're gonna get stuck somewhere you
might as well be prepared to beg the the
dude behind the count of listen I got to
get home I'll give you my ass all I'm
out of money you know I was at Grandma's
house you gota get home what you know if
you I always hated traveling over the
holidays just because of how busy it is
yes especially being in a big airport
and
if these
don't I swear to God I'm gonna choke
with the death I really am I don't even
know who the it is I can't
tell but they gotta stop these
people
[Music]
now they want to text me you stupid
mother if I hear one more thing I'm
gonna stop the podcast and call them and
tell them both you I text you a
half hour ago I sent you that
thing and now I start the podcast and
now is when you get a itch to
call Uncle
Joey I tell you this happens all the
time I told you that I told you
that I am the worst nobody will call all
day and then I'll get five phone
calls in a row from five people I don't
want to hear from and it's in a row like
you don't even put the phone back in
your pocket and Al you see your
shaking I'm like who the is this
before I had some guy call me nice guy I
love him to death I always talk to him
but then I hung up with him then he
called me back like I had to go back in
my pocket what I forgot to tell you if
you're a fan what are you bothering me
for what you listen I'm done with the
conversation we'll talk tomorrow
tomorrow call me tomorrow right I don't
have that no more I'm old I don't have
that once we get off the phone call
me tomorrow we'll start a new
conversation
[Music]
tomorrow do you remember because I I
remember like when we met you then you
like you gave me your number you like
I'll call you and I I waited for it and
then we talked for like two three
minutes which is meant a lot for you but
then you said like I'll call you
tomorrow I'll call you later and I
that's like
eting for probably a day like you like
you just like you like I'll call no
that's what it is I'll call you right
back like if I start talking too much
you're like listen I'll call you right
back and then it's like not like a time
out but like listen it's 8 o'clock it's
late I got 6 700 milligrams you want to
call me and put me on Jeopardy it's not
going to work out you know I'm G tell
you whatever I'm say to get you off the
phone anything yeah I'll do your play
and you roller skate absolutely you know
anything to get you off the phone
because they always call me when I just
sat down to watch something with my wife
they want to call me at
9:20 with hey man are you available
December 8th for what I got a game a
bingo game Hey listen listen call me
tomorrow between 9 and 12 business hours
used to be 9 I got cut him down to 9 to
12 leave a message and we'll get back to
you you go to the gym nobody calls you
all day walking to the gym all of a
sudden it's like you're that girl that
gives in high school my phone
don't stop ringing everybody wants to
give me flowers you know what I'm
saying oh my God I get on the bike right
and right I put the earphones on and
then I have to go my I got to put my
pants in on my my my phone in my
pants bre okay I gotta put my phone in
my pants and I program what an apple now
if you know anything about me it took me
about three months to figure out how to
put the music on Apple like I know I had
Apple but I kept using the same Alum my
wife downloaded 18 years I didn't know
how to figure it out you know how I
figured it out it just came on one
earphon and I'm like what happened there
like it just surprised me I put the
phone earphones next to the
phone in the car and all a sudden the
thing started playing music and
I'm like okay I got
this about my trials and tribulations so
listen I wake up in the morning I have
breakfast my my daughter gets on the bus
I kiss a goodbye I wave at the other
kids have a good day the whole
deal I come in I come back downstairs I
make my notes for the day I wash my
monkey you know couple bongs to get the
wings I'm not just GNA go to the gym at
9:30 on pure excitement I need some
bangets to get the motivation going I
make a little IV drink okay I put some
colustrum in it and I go to the
gym and guess what Lee that's my 30
minutes that's my first 30 minutes of
doing
anything so I figured out if you talk to
me and I take the earphones off now the
earphones don't come back on
oh some guy wants to come over and ask
me did you watch the game last night no
I didn't and I don't give a
say why you bothering me for I got the
earphones on why are you saying
something to me you know I'm a
why are you speaking to me this way they
come over and and then finally I figured
out after another two months how to just
put the earphones back on and then they
land you hear and also
[Laughter]
music now if
somebody some Momo calls me I
could tell because all of a sudden when
you know David Gilmore is gonna
go into a guitar solo that's when you
call me not you I'm saying some
Momo call me right and the phone shuts
off the music shuts off I look
at who's calling I don't want to talk to
you but I gotta wait I gotta wait for
the phone to stop ringing for me
to get back in my tune so you just cut
into 20 seconds of my ride for
something and now I now I get four of
them in 30 I'll get five of them in 30
minutes after I get off that bike that
phone's like a ghost town nobody calls
again so you know whatever the so
that's what I'm trying to say to you
people always you know they know
they got a camera to irritate me there's
a service how to irritate Joey and you
up and you see me doing something that
matters to me and that's when you want
to call me or text me well I'm
just sitting there scratching my balls
begging for somebody to call youever sit
there going I wish somebody called you
ever had those situations where
somebody's giving you an air beating and
you looking at your phone going please
how come these idiots don't call now how
come these F absolutely and then the guy
walks away and then they start calling
you you're like what I can't win I can't
I don't need you now now I'm definitely
not gonna pick up a
phone it's Easy Being Cheesy it's good
to see you
zero sugar for the people who
emailed me Joe do they matter about you
because I drank Snapple yeah Snapples
cherro sugar if you look at my waist
basket here I got 22 Waters so at night
after dinner I like to let go a little
bit you know what I'm saying what's
wrong with a Snapple zero I could see if
I was drinking 22 vodka and
calling bird on the phone and breathing
heavy you know what I'm
saying what
flavor you know me uh zero sugar
Snapple lemon tea yeah I know it's got
chemicals in it but guess what I live in
Jersey so your chemical conspiracy that
ship sailed I grew up in Jersey I
breathed every
psychological come on give me a
breather guys yeah but they use you know
goat's blood okay but it tastes good
they con
me it is good I live on that
know what so I had a hell of a week
last week yeah you people who want to
know why where how come I haven't been
on social media because I can't get to
it all right let me tell you what
happened Wednesday I went for the stress
test and that went okay believe it or
not that wasn't bad the needle and the
arm they don't stick a needle in you now
they stick a plastic thing so
you can play the drums where you got the
intravenous thing in your heart so what
you talking
about the intervenous St the iv put in
your arm isn't a needle it's a plastic
thing and it's
bendable Boom the little Spanish kid put
it in Adrian great guy over at
Center State then they took me to
another room and they
uh sat me down first and they asked me a
bunch of creepy questions you know they
ask you these questions like I know I'm
like what medication are you
listen I have no if you don't see my
wife here don't even bother check all
you got I'm like a prisoner War I don't
know nothing and I don't want to know
nothing
you they start are you on this are you
on that sure
whatever I don't even know what I'm on I
take seven pills in the morning
and five at night I don't know what I'm
on Cline this that
something oh then they put you you no
idea no they put you on a treadmill and
they shoot some ink into you that's got
like
speedly and you think you're gonna
die like I've done it before so
I was mentally prepared this time like I
was I got up early that morning and you
can't eat before you go in there so
whenever I can't eat I don't trust
it it's a 5050 chance that I'm gonna
go down like a bad habit
right
so I go in there it's 8:30 they're
quick they got me right in there
they sat me down you know put the uh the
thing in my arm ABS obviously I take my
earphones with me so I don't hear the
needle or the rubber or whatever the
they're doing and then I uh they
put me in another room and they put you
on a treadmill Le and then they
while you're on the treadmill they shoot
you with some like liquid adrenaline in
like speed to get your to see how much
you could handle it's a stress test my
little chubby heart I got flashbacks at
87 it was I tell him to turn it
off turn it
off I had a tap and they were like are
you okay Mr Diaz yeah I'm okay I sat
down they gave me a cocacola because the
you have to tap huh why did you why did
you tap out because they put the in
I was okay on flat land
but once they started playing with the
directions and up and down
playing with my emotions that's what I
thought I was GNA fall so I I started
panicking about
Val in the
morning I got no coffee in
me
so they sat me down they gave me some
coke and then they did something else
they did you know I had to lay down and
do pictures of my heart and and
they kick me out of there I was I wanted
at 8:30 and I walked out there at 20 to
12 so I was straight as a dog right so I
was like damn I didn't Fain but the next
day I had PRP Thursday prps they take
your blood out and then in and then they
they mix it with some chemicals
and a bunch of Malia juice and then they
it into the location that hurts so I did
it on the one side of the knee but now I
could feel the inside of the knee
starting to go so I went to the doctor
and he's like listen Joy you don't have
you got a couple options but try the PRP
again Insurance don't cover it but it
works for a lot of people and it did
work for me but
on the left side of my knee I had to
double check what hand I was putting
that you know what I'm saying when you
know five Edibles you don't know what
hand you're putting out
so you put this hand up like FR next
thing you
know
so the PRP is at 3:15 in the afternoon
that gives me a chance to smoke doe you
know eat breakfast eat
lunch I was going to go to the gym that
morning but I had my daughter last week
kids were
off and my wife had to go to a banquet
in the morning like a breakfast meeting
thing till 12 so I had my daughter I
just took a shop and whatever we here to
do and then in the afternoon I went to
PRP I went in there with my speakers on
you know I went over to Apex my dog over
there right Dr
srino good dude I've been to him before
you know you don't faint nothing like
that happens to you so I laid back what
arm do you want I go time out with the
right arm they just shot me in there
with a plastic tube yesterday we
gotta switch governments and shoot it
over to the left arm
right so I put on the my usual anthem
when I draw blood I put on Santana oova
I'm one of those dudes I put it on from
the beginning by the time he's taking
the rubber band off my arm and opening
my hand and insert the needle it's
already going so I'm in I feel a little
prick of the needle and then I breathe
it up and they my arm up and I'm like
that didn't hurt at all I could be
strictly honest with you but this one
was
different they stuck the needle in my
arm
and
Lee a minute went by now I'm
going holy I've grown up a lot
because 30 years ago after 10 seconds I
go down I start thinking about it Lee so
the needle was still in your arm for
a whole minute while they were
drawing blood oh no yeah they're
drawing I don't know how many cc's
you're there for a little wild dog and
finally we hit like two minutes I'm two
minutes into this song trust me I've
heard this song 10,000 times and
it's at the two-minute Mark and I'm like
holy I can't believe I haven't
fainted
yet and I didn't even finish thinking
that and he goes He Taps me and he goes
how you doing and I go not bad and he
goes five more seconds and then he took
it out put my arm up I took the
earphones off obviously it turns off
right and I'm talking to them and
brother the next thing you know the room
started getting hot in a I
felt like Nelly and that's why you got
to take your clothes off whatever that
song is it was it was hot in there to
the point where I had to lay back and I
started sliding off the chair it got hot
out of control I started seeing spots
around my eyes and then I said to him
doc can you bring a ice pack for
me and he brought it immediately and I
could feel him put hard ice on my neck
and with this
30 seconds it was
water then he put one on my and one on
my head in the front and all of
them melted within 30 seconds DG
hysterical I drank why do you think you
got so hot just from just my my blood
pressure
dropped you got hot but dog I I made it
without fainting I made it without
complaining I grew up a lot I'm 60 by
this point hopefully you could do
something right you know saying so now I
leave that
joint I'm not going to say the name of
the restaurant they're good people I'm
sitting here at home I come home just to
make sure I'm okay my knee's Fine By the
way bro that's the the easiest procedure
you'll ever do which is which one the
one at Apex this is my second there's
nobody anybody who's been listening to
me for a while my dear friends they all
know I'm not comfortable around needles
I'm just there something about
needles I just don't feel comfortable
around I drive myself down there guys
you know that that's like me driving
myself to get shot in my world okay me
going to the doctor to take a put any
type of needle in me in my head driving
myself to get in front of a
firing squad like I already go in there
feeling gloomy my stomach hurts
and then you read that book and you know
it's called resistance resistance just
doesn't go against you and you're
creative it'll go against your health
there's people that'll die before they
go to the doctor now I'm not
you know friendly with the
doctors but you gotta go in there and
talk to people from time to time and
check things out and yeah I'm very lucky
I didn't go to the doctor from the time
I was 18 till like 30 something you know
I didn't get a physical to moved that
way so yeah it's something like I
struggle with
because like I I lost a good amount of
weight I've put like 20 pounds back on
unfortunately um but I I did you ever
get to the point where like you didn't
my whole thing was I don't want to go
until I'm under a certain
number have any like is that part of
like do your weight go into you not want
to go to the
doctor there was a point where like most
people you're just
embarrassed who wants to go in front of
a doctor when the last time you went in
there you were 260 and now you're 315
and that happens lot way and in that
process you get
diabetes you might get a blood clot in
your leg you know you might you know so
it's worth it like I didn't go to the
doctor for a long time man and knock on
wood I don't know but once I started
going to the doctor I think it felt a
lot better on my scope like that
I'm going to the doctor I'm doing
something for myself for a couple years
then my wife had to drive me you know
because she knew I would make a U-turn
and cancel the
appointment you know that's who I am i'
cancel appointment before going to take
care of myself and then once I got the
hang of it I didn't start fainting I go
to the dentist now I dve myself to the
dentist you know going Joey you're a
grown man what do you mean you Doug I
got problems I don't want to go who
wants to go get stabbed in the
mouth i' rather put a false tooth in
with Scott tape and leave me the
alone we'll f figure it the out but
again you can die from all that you
know and when you're out there doing
drugs and drinking and around a
lot of people you know when you're young
you're
Invincible but at one point that
takes a toll you know and it could be 35
it could be 42 or it could be 29 you
just don't know and you've broken the
barrier of booze so now I come
home I hang out and then I go to
this Del
that you and I both
visit I had a sandwich there in fact I
couldn't eat the whole sandwich I had a
half the sandwich I didn't eat the
coasta and I had
uh a half a sandwich oh a cup of soup
that's all I could do like you know from
fainting I guess I was still not really
hungry but I just wanted to eat
something so I wouldn't be hungry at
10:15 at night and then I start
panicking for reals
so I get up and you know I've been there
200 times in three years it's one of my
favorite
delies I was looking down but it's usual
where the customers walk out and when I
went to make the right turn I got my
foot got caught on like a couple mats
and stuff like that and I went down and
and dog I was out of it for a
minute like I kept it together I P the
Mexican came over he's like we put the
mats down I'm like you know
iand on the floor I didn't even go for
it I just got up limped out of there I
walked out I got in the car and I drove
home still probably in shock you know I
came home and I chilled and about an
hour later my leg started
hurt and then about an hour later my
wife came home with Mercy they were
doing something and my wife goes
let me see it and she's like Joey this
thing's starting to swell up and that
night I did not sleep at all at all I
finally got out of bed at 6 and I just
went to the living room and one of the
girls who was staying here that night
the mom text me she goes how' the night
going I go great and she goes I could
see you're up early I go yeah I'm always
up you know early in the morning and she
goes how was your night and I go I
fell last night I thought I
ripped my achilles tendon because my leg
got really hard in the middle of
the night like I couldn't even go to the
bathroom like it was real guys so she
made a call for me cuz she just had
achiles surh surgery and they got me in
there thank God it's just some tendons
that I stretch and a few
muscles and dog I don't wish to paint on
anybody especially when I stand on it so
I'm pretty much sitting here for three
days like a Swami with no salami I'm
pissing in the bottle because
the pain pills they gave me I haven't
taken his so I'm back up I started
eating antibiotics and I've been farts
that smell like nework so it's coming
out in any time now I'm going have to
crawl to the bathroom like
Lazarus just
to come back dog I cannot step on it I
cannot step like it's that's scary
that's a scary time in your life when
you know I can't step on it if
there's a fire I'm getting lit up I
ain't going nowhere you got to drag me
out of
here Jesus Christ why you think there's
going to be a fire in there there's not
going to be a fire this is how you have
to think that's why when I see you don't
that's anxiety think no it's not anxiety
it's planning ahead it's like when I see
people and they're at a bar and
they got flipflops on what if a fight
breaks out and somebody steps on your
foot you lose your flipflop and you get
a beaten because you lost your flipflop
now you got to walk home without a
flipflop on a black eye who wants to
live like that do you so you ahead
you're going to go to a bar you wear
some combat boots gets down
you're sidekicking
even though you don't know karate it
might save your life up ahead
what you think you're dealing with Jo
bananas I'm just trying to drop it on
you while it's hot I haven't been able
to have flip poops for like over a
decade now and tonight I did eat uh
three abx's but I mix them with these
what are
those milk chocolate see the milligram
I can't what is it I have no idea tell
the people I'm blind as a b the whole
bar is
2500 Jesus
christes
muches
domes boom you get 16
pieces so do the math quick you're an
accountant I am an account account boom
let's do
it 16
pieces no four
16 156 and a quarter P right yeah so
right here you got 156 Time
625 salude it's Tuesday morning you know
what I'm saying get your life together
boys and girls it's getting real out
there you ain't got time to think and
procrastinate this is it I got to adjust
this all you can see is my big nose all
right whatever that'll
work that works buddy and now for a word
from our
sponsor hey let's take a break from the
check in listen there's really a lot to
be thankful for this year but draftking
seriously tops the list I'll tell you
why draftking sports book is keeping
your Thanksgiving week filled with
action new customer can bet just $5 on
the NFL action to score 150 instantly in
bonus Bets did you hear what I just said
to you new customers can bet just five
bucks on NFL action to score 150
instantly in bonus bets whatever you're
into money lines paray prop bets live
bets listen DraftKings has it all he's
like Ted Nan in 79 UPS Downs Gorilla
Biscuits whatever you need Uncle Ted had
it anyway listen get a little extra
Pocket Change this year for that Black
Friday shopping with DraftKings you know
me guys I love DraftKings whether it's
the sport book or Casino I rock both of
those thingss so do yourself a favor
download the draftking sports book right
now and pressing Co Joey Joe y listen
let's stop the charade here you messed
around with the rest it's time to come
with Uncle Joey the draft k
do yourself a favor DraftKings is the
official sports book and sports betting
partner of the NFL with code Joey again
new customers can bet five bucks on the
NFL Thanksgiving action to score 150
instantly in bonus bets $5 guys the
crown will be yours you have a good
Thanksgiving everybody jumps up and down
now if you got a gambling problem called
100 gamble if you're in New York call
18778 dhop New York or text Hope new
york46
7369 if you're okay you got yourself in
check download the draft King sports
book app Preston code Joey and let's get
the party started get your $5 get 150 in
bets and play a little uh Wheel of
Fortune I love you guys and now back to
the show
we're back you savages the
chocolate was delicious and now we're
here Lee what's going on with you why
you drinking water
for because I'm thirsty another 600 you
know what I'm saying Jesus CH no
training well I trained this weekend
because I had no choice I had the pain
in my legs so the first night I tried to
be a Boy Scout and not take the Edibles
I broke down on Friday night at about
like 800 and you know what what's crazy
you know they sell marijuana as this it
helps with anxiety it helps you sleep it
releases pain it relieves pain you read
these things and you go I don't know I
don't know and then you get a
toothache and there's no pain medication
you're taking tlol Advil a leave
nothing's working you're on your third
day and one night you just wake up and
you're frustrated you smoke some reer
you see what happens you're going to put
the joint away wake up and say
Joey's a jerk off and you're going to
get iced you're going to put it on your
face and lay there and put the TV on and
watch the news and next thing you know
you're going to realize you don't hurt
because it took your mind away from
it that's what it does it takes your
mind away from the pain and listen
you're still going to have pain but
you're even going to go holy my
pain went away for 20 minutes that's
weird and as much as you don't
want to say Well it must have been the
Comfort sauce my grandmother brought
from Poland just you know because I tell
you I don't believe that
statement St but you know I got my
medical marijuana license the first time
on an anxiety No
Sleep uh basis do I get anxiety yes and
can I that my my biggest one is sleep
but for years I always smoked in the
morning and then never throughout the
day and then at night so I would get
really double blasted and I could fall
asleep it would be like eating in edible
for me back then but you know 50 years
shit's going to happen to the lungs and
your body adjust to different things and
now you know I live with that so what up
with you how's comedy dog enough about
me where the where the you
been how many shows you do last week I
did a lot I did probably I did probably
eight to 10 listen when I on Tuesdays I
want a
number you should always what did we
discussed last week I your T-shirt with
how many sets you did and broke them
down at all times like if you come to my
country I'm gonna check your your
credentials what' you do last week I did
nine spots I ate three dicks you know
one of them was weird that didn't speak
English you know wait till you get hired
for one of
those a non-english speaking Crow oh
yeah I don't think I've done that but
they always throw a decoy at you they
throw the two white cousins and one of
them is probably a hot chick and that's
how they sell you on going in there and
then you get in there and it's it's
always a surprise as you're walking
through the the doors to get there you
get that certain scent I'm not throwing
anybody under the bus
here you go back there you're throwing
your aerial and they're all looking at
you weird you get to check as you're
walking out you're like what happened
they're like oh they don't speak English
didn't they then why'd you bring me here
I just went up there I could have gone
up there played a kazoo and they would
have liked it more than me
just have you got have you gotten the
Kazo yet though
no what do you mean a kazoo you want me
to get a kazoo in case I start bombing
you and you should go on stage when joke
bombs hit the kazoo one
time if you hit if you die with four
jokes you hit the kazoo four times
baboom somehow I don't think that people
are gonna like that yeah who knows you
got to try everything for a while you're
just buying time to you become one of
the biggest comedy Stars in the world so
this is when you
experiment I have to have the kazoo
every time I bomb like I remember early
on like my second third year I was
bombing especially at that place as a
host I was just going up there a bomb oh
there during the feature Act and the
headliner with a straight face like
nothing happened like I don't drink but
right off I got on stage I'd be drinking
like double rum and cokes and
like I don't even know what I drank
back then but you know it was uh I had
to figure out how to be better than the
than the earlier week and I still
remember as corny as it is putting on a
Madonna thing like the vog video with
the cones I actually dug that down and
dirty and put the cones on one time in
like 93 I mean it doesn't count now it's
not on record but I'm telling you the
truth uh I don't know the stupid I
did but for a couple weeks I had
improvised because it was the same
audience Le it was remember it was $15
to get in and you got a prime rib with a
baked potato and a free bowl of
shrimp so they went to watch the comedy
and I would say they didn't really want
to watch Comedy no they went there for
the for $15 steak if you pay for
the steak you got a free comedy ticket
right so that was the hang that you
stayed for the thing you know how many
times
you couldn't even get them to look
up I've done those yeah D they're eating
and that prime rib honest to God was a
lot better than I was back then and they
would eat right in front of you and then
I remember going home and going I get it
I'm not going to get laughs I'm going to
get these Savages to just look at me and
that's how I started I just broke it
down into different levels I was there
for two years man and listen when I got
out of there I was still a shitty comic
but I had a good understanding of what
was going on because I worked with
national Headliners every week they
weren't the best national Headliners but
I worked with a lot of people I I caught
up with years later in LA and I schol oh
my God we worked at the broker in 92 oh
that's right so it's kind of weird
you know so you never
know but
it the host is is crazy like I was I had
I got asked to feature
randomly uh or out of the blue on Friday
and I had like
probably I I told you like I I felt like
I was bombing in front of like managers
or uh like Bookers and I did so well
like they came over and hugged me like I
did I had probably one of the best sets
my time doing standup and I could hear
when you spoke to me that night that you
were very very happy oh I like it was it
just everything went well and like it
just well you know what it this weekend
showed me was how important the audience
is like like just but like not like how
like how they can change things but and
then Saturday I went to
host and the same
material just like they weren't they
were just smile like they were smiling
like they were happy but they just
didn't I would just say things
that 24 hours earlier was getting hugs
and then they would just like not even
at
all the hosting part is so foreign to me
I feel like I feel like I've been doing
pretty well as a stand up and I'm like
I'm not like not doing a great job as a
host okay you gotta tackle your fears
you got to tackle the that you're
having a hard time with like I said
anybody could
feature and anybody could headline real
quick you see how it happens and then
they become Headliners in your area and
that's what they do the rest of their
lives and I don't know I was always very
I don't know what the word is Noble or
whatever that I thought that I had to
become then it was listen featuring on
Tuesday nights for me at that place
after like two years I got it down but
then I went on the road as an MC no no I
mean mcing at the boulder
broker I was you know I didn't kill
every week but towards the end I knew
how to work the room a lot better when I
walked in
there but the true test was going on the
road as an
MC and learning the business side of it
and that's a side right there that kills
most people like the announcements you
have to make huh like the the
announcements you have to make like what
do you mean the business side of you
know welcome you come up on stage okay
what's going on my name is Lisa yeah
yeah I'm Jewish I get it blah blah blah
you do your 30 minutes you get the
off
stage okay by this by the by the I don't
know 60 seconds they know if they like
you or they don't okay like anything
else in life now you're coming up going
welcome to Lisi at comedy club
my name is Pete patella Welcome to our
show we got a great headliner for you
tonight Joe Rogan's in the house your
feature act Joey Diaz and uh we're gonna
have a great show don't forget the
special of the night tonight is the
burning if you buy one you get
one free now you gotta write it you know
I don't even know if it's burning
it could be a greyhound it could
be a martini but you just went from
becoming a comic to kind of becoming a
Salesman and then you four minutes of
material and you'll get a light and the
guy goes and don't forget coming in
coming next week is uh you know
crystalia and then the week after and
that's great I want you to learn how to
go coming next week the Great crystalia
and the week after that Whitney
Cummings is coming
whatever that's comedy club Owners
that'll make you read the whole
calendar from September 24th all the way
and don't
forget the host of The Morning Show will
be here on New Year's Eve doing his
thing and you actually have to go up
there and go New Year's Eve dog it just
took you away for three minutes of your
15 minutes you just had to talk
about the schedule who's going to be
there and the two drink minimum and now
you got to go back to your material it
takes Houdini to do that you're
not gonna walk off the street and just
do that like that yeah you might pull
off one or maybe two times but
eventually you're going to catch up with
it you're going to struggle
until you you know how to balance it it
took me years to become a host and once
I became a feature act I still missed it
even in Seattle I still kept like Joey
Diaz on Wednesday nights we' do Joey
Diaz and his flying mambos and it was
always Brody Josh and then Tuesday night
it was an open mic Monday night was some
and Thursday night if the headliner was
only working Friday and Saturday it was
Brody's show got rest to soul and it was
uh me Josh Wolf the same thing
we only
rotated I did those yeah I did it for
the small 50 but I did those
because somewhere in me I wanted to
learn how to host and I still remember
going to The Comedy Store years later
now was a feature on the road The Comedy
Store has 15 minute
spots and one day like after I was there
like
I don't know two
years Freddy SoDo offered me the driving
job in the van it was 15 hours a week
and I'm at the store mingling and I
was already a regular so I wasn't doing
it to be in anybody's ass I was already
in I was just looking for something to
do in the daytime and it paid I don't
know 10 bucks an hour or whatever 12 an
hour you went to the bank you made
deposits you picked up lumber at the
Hardware storm Beverly Hills and
you picked up a tongue sandwich from
itsy Shore God Rest us soul that was
your job from 12 to 5: or from 10 to5
that was your job on Friday and then you
got paid and you went to La Hoya or you
went and you did a Friday night gig
somewhere and then Freddy didn't want
the hosting gate so he's like Joey you
wanted it pays 25 bucks and I'm like
which one the tent to
clothes that's when the Hits come in and
I had been doing them every
Sunday and I really wanted to just host
on the hits came in and dog that made me
a killer that really did at that
level was I I was headliner was I a real
headliner no I was just getting
12500 a week it was a little extra in a
plane ticket that's why I was doing the
and I had a manager who booked me at
these clubs I wasn't a headliner I was a
mediocre feature with 28 minutes I had a
stretch now to 45 how bad do you really
think I was really B unless I
improvised and hit the lottery that
night but unless and that you know
that's when you did Tuesday through
Sunday so time yeah you did Tuesday
through Sunday you sounds awesome Monday
you did laundry Monday night you you
hugged up with your girlfriend you
bought some weed and you got back on a
plane Tuesday Morning
G
Jes I'm sure it gets old but did you
like it for a little bit like when you
first started doing like I'm doing
all these shows then they added the
midnight show on
Saturday and I was the king of those I
loved them and I remember one time
Buffalo haded one the funny bone and you
know me dog I'm the type of
if you got a party and it's going to be
good I'm going to go up there I actually
called the funny bone they're like stop
by
we'll cover your hotel and give you
percentage of the door I walked in there
it was like Madison Square Garden on a
Saturday night it was like madis
Square gun because the people come over
from
Canada wow come on now son it's sat like
3220 people they had wings in there they
had all buffalo it was
across the street from a Wegman's and
their wings were even bigger than
The Comedy Club
it was a great experience so I started
doing it anytime I was in this area I
would stop in Buffalo on Saturday night
get the hotel room hang out with the
owner and then he closed the
club the owner robbed the place he
became the Gambler in the rest of his
history the buffalo funny bone went
down that's how quick it goes down so
appreciate it while you got it that's a
lesson you know what I'm
saying shocking ending oh my God what
how long ago was
this this had to be
98 I remember I started there with Steve
McGrew that was Steve mcgrew's feature
Thanksgiving week again it started
Tuesday Wednesday and that week we had
Thursday off but Friday be became a Five
Spot
weekend so from Friday to day and then
we did the midnight show so as a feature
back then I would make okay money in
Buffalo showing up for one night on
Saturday the owner liked me I liked him
I liked what he was doing it just wasn't
a show he put music he had a DJ he was
already doing that in
98 he was already doing that the front
was a party there was an Afterparty for
the show he did the midnight show right
you know but then people just became
Acts
they would start the midnight show at
12:45 why have a midnight
show because the went over his
time on purpose because he's a
prick head so when the 124 the 1245
everybody was doing midnight shows and
they started at 12:45 you know how long
that show last it should last a half
hour it should last
half that's it you're not going to hold
their attention they're already three
quarters in the bag now you made them
wait for 45 minutes outside whatever
it's raining it's snowing it's 90° you
know how do you think they're gonna
be and I'm not predetermining an
audience I don't want you to think I'm
doing that but imagine imagine on a
Saturday you paid for a babysitter
midnight show you got a hotel room so
you can bang her till six she's
got to go home and Mom three kids you
know whatever the story is I don't know
what the story you know what I'm saying
but that's uh
that's the reality of
it I always wondered because I always
thought like going to The Late Show
would be better as like a fan because I
thought like the comic would have more
time to like around but like as a
comic the early shows I think you're
right like the first thing when you said
midnight show like oh they're gonna be
drunk they're gonna be like H really
yeah Hamond it's Saturday night what the
do you think they did they met at
8:00 for dinner and they started
pounding
martinis and after dessert came they
started doing lines of coke because you
can't control yourself you tell yourself
I'm gonna hold on to it till the comic
almost gets off Ah that's never gonna
happen so now you're
chatty right now you give some to your
girlfriend and she gives some to your
girlfriend and now three people out of
six are chip chatting at the
table so trust me I've gone through all
this that's why you don't see too
many midnight shows anymore they just
finally said it's uh it's a recipe for
Destruction it became I don't like
starting a show late like that okay
listen we got to start at 1210 I could
live with that
12:45 I want my money back come on man
12:45 that means leave yeah I'm not
going to get a cocktail to
one I used to do those in Miami dog and
I learned the rough comedy at midnight
but I also told them if I feat I'm only
doing 20 minutes what do you mean dog
your attention span you're just killing
yourself to live they're really here to
see the
headliner they're really here to see the
headliner the place is sold out not
because I'm headlining but because
whoever it is is headl
let him do 45 I do 15 the MC does 10 and
we get the out of here that doesn't
sound like a bad idea yeah and now the
natives won't be
restless we could do what the we do
so yeah I don't know how long I'm gonna
be down for I don't know if I you know
this is it and I've been enjoying it you
know I live in the basement pretty much
I can't even go upstairs to my
bed no you don't go upstairs you no I
can't go up two flights of stairs
there's no way I'll break the
it's just too painful I have to
take a I have to take a bath standing up
like a prisoner war in my living room
naked with a towel underneath
me you
know I got a shave War a shave today
without a heat shower are you
kidding me had to shave like
raw like prison show when I do
that I always think of is it like
got to shave without you can't
shave in a shower some you'll shave your
and stab you 10 times
you got to have your hands close to
kulo yeah I don't think you're shaving
what in the in in prison are you no no
no you grow a beard look like Ari yeah
you shave in prison well I me
like your face like I'm not like you're
like the rest of your party oh let me
tell you something you put a razor to
your balls 99 to one ey you're going
down in a in the men's something
they're just GNA find you mangled to
death with a ball in your mouth
with an apple that says I love
sandals you won't be hearing from him no
more oh I have no
idea oh yeah you go in that show and
fight it's like that scene in
uh The Wolf of Wall Street when the
guy's cleaning out his fish tank and
crazy takes the fish out and eats
it they throw the guy out get the
out they throw the guy out listen in
prison if you even pull that like
you go a shower with a
manscape within eight minutes that's it
you're gonna get gang raped and they're
just gonna stab you and they're gonna do
it for you you got 16 years anyway
you're shaving your balls it ain't gonna
last for
you holy
if you're in prison you gotta stay
primitive hairy armpits your eyebrows
gotta go up you don't brush your
teeth that's what I thought huh that's
what I thought that's why I was like I
brush my I cannot brush my teeth oh yeah
you have to brush your teeth you gotta
brush your teeth that's you gotta be
primitive you gotta be ready to bite a
that's another weapon I bit
that and I didn't brush my
teeth for 89
days something happen to
him
it's quite a
quote
you I'm
e I'm eating sardines and you know
I got growing in my mouth I'm
eating sushi at night you want to
with me I'll bite you in the
neck you'll go down like 24
hours it's not going to kill you
immediately got like a snake biting you
in the neck and shooting that poison
that makes you phone from the mouth
but but what I don't
know the Edibles have kicked in the
chocolate's kicked in you
know yes they have oh my god oh yeah I
forgot you took more Jesus Christ
another 600 it's Tuesday I don't have to
see the doctor till
Wednesday that helps with your it's a
zoom meeting with the doctor it's tella
Health we you think dealing with Joey
bananas I actually had a I was wondering
your opinion on something hit me hold on
this a that sounds like Willie
cologne's trombone that one anyway go
ahead are you in your living room who
are you in the basement I'm telling you
nobody can hear this they hiding my
upstairs they got the soundproof room up
there they don't want Mercy to hear
anything of it the cat was here for a
little while that's the first time I had
a real life animal in studio the cat was
here chilling he just she just left
about seven minutes ago I didn't know
she was there that's funny oh you bet
thing this week did you lose any money
no I actually won to say what you were
gonna say I'm sorry you had some oh okay
well I have I can talk about betting too
but um I was wondering like what your
opinion on work from home is like cuz I
was talking with somebody and he was
saying he got his job switched to work
from home and it's driving him n a
little bit not going into the
office and I've been doing it for two
years and it's you know listen I have
opinions if I tell you that I'm giving
you a job and you could stay at home and
not wash your feet and being your
underwear till 5 o'l a little
Herman like yourself will
take the job because you actually enjoy
being home
you actually you told me you didn't like
going into the office when I used to
make you edit all the jobs were at night
anyway can you imagine having a night
job editing out of your
house no on oh yeah your refrigerator
your food you're prepared you're going
to be up all night if you want to do
something and take a nap for 35 minutes
you can so the problem with listen when
coid came and people people fell in love
with the IDE working from home who
wouldn't who wouldn't you know I
could see if I work 10 minutes from here
but could you imagine if you lived where
I lived and had to get into the city
every day by 7:30 in the morning you got
to leave here at 5: in the
morning in the dead of the winter and
land in Port Authority and God
knows what could happen to you five in
the morning outside of Port
Authority and then you have to walk some
more to your job or whatever so what was
the question like what you thought about
work from home
so then they offer you working
from home and it's pretty cool
but I really don't know what you're
doing and a couple years ago I remember
you and I discussing this that they did
like a survey of how much people really
work from their job about like
2015 I remember discussing this with
somebody they did a survey of how
much it people people who work in
offices actually work in an8 hour day
they work like three and a half hours
because there's too much to fidget
around with so my point is if that could
happen to you in an office what's going
to happen to you at home when your
girlfriend just came out of the shower
and she walks past you with a thong on
and no top on to pour coffee you're
gonna pull that Zoom
wire the wi is are going down may
may you pulling that wire you know so I
know if I'm a business owner do I want
people working from home five days a
week I don't see these people listen if
I was doing powder in my day and you
gave me a day job in the house are you
kidding
me are you kidding me with
it that's half the party right there I
don't have to get up in the morning I
just got to go on the computer and go
you know what my camera's not working
and hit the blackout and I could talk
do Coke like what's his name uh
the dude from Wolf on Wall Street bisha
Toro whatever his name is I
don't
know
yeah what name
isoro I don't know it's one of those
names gioan whatever his
name is Giovani gianini why' you give
him one name for and confuse the
out of me Giovani gianini and
so I think
that if the employee
is I think that what the are you
laughing about here I forgot what we
were talking about like I trust you if I
own a top 500 company and I had to pay
you 250 and you were the the backbone of
the operation and you said to me I'd
rather work from home I got a kid and a
daughter and my wife's pregnant I trust
you I'm going to go there one time I
want to look at your operation I want to
make sure the refrigerator is not next
to you and I'm going to give you a few
books on
organizing so you know this is great for
people you know Joey I always thought
about joining a yoga class
there's one at 10 o'clock so that means
now after you put your kid on the bus
you could run in and work from 800 to
9:30 get the morning started send out
your emails go to your yoga class stop
for a smoothie comeback there's no kids
around so now you go straight till 3
o'clock right you can go straight till 3
4 whenever the baby should have picks
him up whenever the you need to
pick them up so now we know we have an
understanding you're going to
work eight to three five days a week and
three days you're going to work 8 to
9:30 and whatever she go to yoga I could
live with that
LE I could live with that we timed your
day out you have a great schedule when
you come back I'd rather you go to yoga
at 10: you know why because whatever
problems you got in the morning you
could work out your brain during yoga so
when you come back I'm going to get
better time out of you you're going to
be better mentally prepared you're not g
to have any days the edible I gave you
last night is going to be out because
you sweat it all out at yoga even if you
just go to regular yoga you understand
my point here whether it's yoga karate
lifting weight
if you want to play one of those
swords with a mask on I want you to get
out because you're going to be stale to
me at 12:30 I know
this I know this you're gonna be stale
the same way I would be
stale I know when I get up in the
morning I want to leave the
house run out of here naked and run
through the bushes for three minutes and
then walk back with my earphones
on and listening to music you know then
I want to do some work because I planned
out my day in that little exercise
movement when I walk the neighborhood
for 20 minutes in the morning I have a
way better
daily and then I do what I got to do and
I stop at the gym or I go to
Jiu-Jitsu whenever I take that 20 minute
walk I have a way better day so and and
like did me like mentally you have a
better day
yes
yes and how what made like how did you
just figure out that was the like the
Difference Maker
like I think we're human beings we're
getting a lot of thrown at
us now you going to a job at 8 o'clock
and the world's falling apart the UPS
drive we got a flat so he's running late
the artwork is running late this
guy didn't show up to work because he
got arrested last night and now you got
to deal with all this by 10 o'clock with
all the that's getting into your
mind now you need this at your job how
you gonna be the rest of the day if I
let you take a breather at 10 o'clock
because I trust you and you trust me
we'll switch it up I'll come in three
days a week and cover your you come
in Tuesday and and Thursday and cover
mine and at least you get out you're not
in the house for eight hours I
don't know anybody that should be in a
house from 8 to 4 working for
anybody that's just my opinion because I
can't do it that's like being in prison
you want to be in
prison I think that's what a lot of
people are doing like that's and I I
like my job but mine's eight to
five well it's it is it is a lot of
listen America gives you all these
survey numbers all the time and I think
sometimes they pull the numbers out of
their ass I'm no major league
Economist but I think any smart person
will tell you you're trying to as an
employer I'm trying to get the best Lee
I
can I'm trying to get the best Lee I
can so do I think personally I want to
keep Lee in the house and underwear and
a nice plaid jacket on from
9 to
three without getting the dose of
sunlight you want to stay in the 8: to
10: and go for a walk for an hour and
come back at 12:00 eat a sandwich and
get back on the computer I'm okay with
that
too yeah they they definitely talk about
especially I mean it's it's something I
was doing a lot of and I I definitely I
would I would agree actually makes a lot
of sense now let's say you have to work
and your wife is home I love my wife I
love my wife when I do these I don't
want her lurking
so now you have to work in the mornings
and she's in the other room Lee you
never told me about that wedding on
December 26 meanwhile you got some guy
from some podcast company you got
another guy on hold you got a zoom his
camera went out and she wants to know if
you go to the wedding on November 26
hold on let me get the gun you
know what I'm saying like hold on I need
this right now December 26 so there's so
many distractions at the
house that's the
other so it all depends it all depends
what you could do that's my opinion on
it listen me I want to work at the house
but guess what I'm not sitting here all
day so let me get SC doodle out
of here let me catch Jiu-Jitsu from 12:
to 1 three times a week and after that I
won't break your
Bulls but Tuesday and Thursday I'm gonna
be the best Joey Diaz you'll
ever see because I got Peace of Mind
from going to jiu-jitsu I want you to do
something I don't want you to sit in the
desk no vitamin D eating process
food hunched over I'm just going to get
an employe you know I don't want that
either everybody says they everybody
always says you know I'm concerned about
you Lee well then help me you know don't
bring 22 cheeseburgers to my house and
the F you know it's just so weird
everybody wants to help you but
uh not that's just my opinion Le you
know I'm a married man I got a kid in
here I couldn't imagine having to do
work in my back office with Mercy
lurking
around
right is it's different but when there's
like School versus no school like the
summer is definitely different you were
asking me about
uh about gambling
too how'd you do this weekend tan I
actually won two
bets yes I won like
$55 I went to the I went to the casino
twice I played blackjack it was fun at
the casino or online at the casino they
don't have it on the app in massach like
you for
example I know you and I know you love
walking through a casino oh yeah seen
you in a casino and I've seen your whole
mood chill and you're very excited and
it's the first time your feet don't hurt
you just just free in a casino you know
what I'm saying you're like a gay dude
on gay pride you're just roaming the
street jumping up and down with no
bikini
on so like draft King Casino any
Cino you like it but not
really I like it but it's it's
um I like being in person i i i i
because I love playing cards I will play
cards it's always fun to play cards me
on the other hand I would love to go and
play uh slots and maybe play a
dollar table with blackjack with you but
then I think about the drive to AC
parking walking down there am I gonna
get mugged on the way out am i g to get
hit in the head when I get my car I mean
and it's a lot of walking down
there so you better bring your roller
skates so I can't do any of that
so I love doing what I got to do
and my 11:30 little break is doing a
little draftking Casino I'll do that
before I have to go to Jiu-Jitsu I'll
give myself a 15 minute
window and have a good time by
myself there I love whenever the jersey
and then the rest of the day I'm off I
don't have to do dick I don't have to
gamble I don't know woman the
woman of the BET tonight I have no idea
it's buffalo against somebody I have no
idea but it's Monday night you never
know what's going to happen everybody's
saying that Buffalo hasn't uh covered
the last four weeks or the last four
Prime Time game I'm not in those stats
anyways so you look at it you see what
you like and take your chances shorty
you know what I'm
saying it's fun how do you feel about
your comedy lately Lee do you feel a
growth I do it's weird
confidence it was very strange I had
like one of the best and one of like the
worst sets of my life like back to back
which was fun um but I feel like I am
getting a lot better like and that's
what you said because I called you and I
was like I asked you a question and we
were talking about hosting and you're
like well when you're ready to feature
well you'll feature like well I feel
like I am a pretty good feat like I
honestly do feel like I can do a very
good feature job but
hosting which is very different so like
I'm as good as I feel like I'm doing in
some ways I'm like I found out I'm not
doing very well and others well I'll
tell you
what right
now if I was managing you with a
plan right now I would keep you out
of the a rooms as a feature and if they
wanted to MC you I would keep you MC in
there and get them to fall in love with
Lee even though I don't think I'm that
good of a host nope yeah
yeah yeah because they're not really
worried they're going to watch you
you're likable you don't drink you don't
cause no problems you get some laughs up
there you get along with the feature
you're on time there's so many other
things they really look
and then you got a credit you got a
credit and all of a sudden boom there
you are right now the love you're gonna
get 85% of is from bom featuring they're
gonna put you on instantly you
know right now a room featuring first of
all the truth of the matter is
Headliners bring their own features so
why compete with something that you're
going to get frustrated over nothing you
can do you go to the comedy store every
night and stand there and wait
for Mitsy Shore to plead your case she
made her decision get the out of
here disappear for a year dye your hair
purple write some material and stop your
whining do you follow I'm saying to you
the attitude I came from right so you
go to those B rooms you pick up
20 weeks of work in those
beds I like to connect you with
somebody
it's one of those guys where he did some
good stuff for me never any good money
always got me gigs but there was always
a by the way it was always $50 different
there was no hotel and I wouldn't get to
no hotels till I just drove six hours
and I was pulling my
luggage out of the back and
they're like oh there's no Hotel here
tonight
where's the hotel you gotta drive 90
miles that way to get what are you
talking about I'm in there doing doubles
it never dawned on you I'm in there
snorting bazooka hits in the
bathroom it never dawned on you you to
tap me on the shoulder and say do you
have a ride home it's I mean there was s
just so many one night in Baltimore
stands out where I got there and I go we
never got a hotel in the club on there
ain't no Hotel here he knew that I asked
the feature what are you going to do she
goes like day the guy lives down here
I'm like
and it was one of those gigs where
oh yeah you didn't get paid oh he'll pay
you on Monday so here I am in
Baltimore with the small 20 in my pocket
a half a joint and four cigarettes
you're not going to pay me and
there's no hotel
room so I thought of hooking them up
with you but I can't it's not worth the
aggravation he he he got me gigs but
they were never good gigs I mean this
guy got me a gig one time on a bus and I
I went
just I would do a bus I did it for the
small it was 75
bucks that's a
lot 75 bucks I had to be there 7 in the
morning go back and forth to New York
like two or three times oh okay I
thought it was one spot no must I tell
you the results of doing comedy on the
bus when you're stuck in traffic they
shooting that suicide smoke when you're
going the tunnel people
breathing heavy you're up there listen I
just came back from Nebraska listen that
that's the last thing they want to hear
they headed to the Disney mall
to jump up and down with the other
Momos who goes to New York yeah
we're gonna go to Disney what the
Disney you go to New York the finger a
you go to New York to have some
fun you know what I'm saying knock it
off oh my
God and you had to do it three
times where the
[Laughter]
bus let me ask you something does it
matter I don't know four
we were out of there like by one
o00 and then they said you're G to get
paid afterward and then there was a bite
away to that and then uh we
never got an envelope from
that I
forget I forget the it was a female
comic who put the gig
together and this book of got it
all done and we never got a dime from
it
so what are you gonna do you learn from
Comedy but you know what nah it's not
worth the aggravation you do better
doing other things gr you want to come
to say hello to people out there in
podcastville she doesn't give a
Frenchman's about but she's been
tremendous like the f I had to sleep
down here on Friday night guys J I don't
like sleeping on a recliner no
it sucks those Edibles I did a couple
bong hits I did the pain
medication they gave me I sat on this
couch and
within like 10 minutes I had to put my
whoop thing to tell them I'm
going to sleep I got up like a four to
pee I pee in my little bottle I hide it
behind the
bung and then I get up like at s
and I pee again and like I said since
Friday morning let me see no
since Friday night is when I started
sleeping down here since
Saturday I've been down here guys
watching old on Hulu
reading stuff in the computer you know
trying to learn about the ankle how I
can help recover it I'm hitting
it with a massage gun I put it
in epson salt my wife's been great you
know so it's gonna be a I thought I you
know I thought I'd be Tip Top myo by
tomorrow I'd be doing ballet doesn't
look that way guys so I'm lock
for a few days is that what they say
they just need rest and like rehab is
that all you need is it they'll decide
in two weeks if I have to go for
physical
therapy so I'm sorry about the tour
I had to
cancel aan nights in Mambo I was doing
my little Mambo presentation next year
ticket that you heard you were gonna be
the opening comedian oh a you had a wear
a tux I was in a surprise young
Christmas with a checky poo a contract
and
we were going to start the tour February
I forget what the the last
Friday in
February we're going to go to Two Towns
every weekend for eight weeks I was
going to have bring a DJ with me TJ
English and you would be the opening MC
with a tuxedo we'd have to give you a
couple words to say in English in
Spanish by that time we don't know where
the war is going to be so you have to
lose the beard so you could travel with
us under the Alias he's not
Jewish he's Cuban you know what I'm
saying let please we'll get you a little
passport Jose Mendes or something I will
send you LA to that Park what's that
park by uh langers not Griffith
it's um the dangerous one yeah I know
what you're talking about across the
street you ask for a dude named
uh kamacho kamano Blanco kamacho
something with a c and you got
everything brand new he gives
you everything a prescription for you
new glasses he's got everything One Stop
shopping I think it's 1,500 for 2,000 he
he gives you a lottery ticket for a
$1,000 Mexican Lottery and if he
win he win like 800,000 he takes 8 10%
you walk out of there with $720,000
and you're all tuned up who's better
than you on a
Sunday I love
it so I have to change my ident is what
you're saying yeah just in case get
dang why are get dang huh why are things
gonna get dang
listen right now with things are going
on you don't know what direction where
the coin's going to land here and it
could happen whatever so just
pray and uh keep your thoughts pure and
that's it Su can take care of
yourself and make sure you do your spots
and know how many sets you did every
week and what your goal is every
month that's the most important thing
you
know when you're doing eight sets a week
six sets a week I can't have you
sweating one set one of the biggest pain
right now this is happening to you gr
come over here and say hello to the
people on television L what do you think
of
zomble
uh you know you you looking when you
were telling me the story I thought
about going like in 99
2000 going to Houston for the weekend
somebody would fall out and Pete would
put me in there or mark babbit and it
was money but they put me in a
hotel they take me to dinner a couple
times I bought some blow when I was
there it was a nice little weekend you
know and guess what you kicked ass all
five shows you didn't sell out
you s sold out one show on Saturday and
those days you know even if you were
cancelled you could sell out the the
Saturday night there it was a comedy
Town it was a comedy place and
here you are kicking ass Thursday night
two shows Friday two Saturday but you
got something on Monday so you leave
Sunday and you go to The Comedy Store
Popp it you just had five great sets in
the
Houston the same material you
take your 30 minute set that was on fire
or your 45 minute set and you cut it
down to 19 I know MIT gives you 20
minutes you want to cut it to 18 just to
see how the week ends and then you could
start writing something else so this is
going to be your best set of the week
they bring you up this guy's great he
just did this coming to the stage leisi
at you're pumped from the five
shows you just did in Houston Texas you
go on the original room and not one of
your jokes
work and how you feel
that this is going to happen
forever feel awful and it doesn't make
any sense it makes a ton of sense we set
out the urge
the we send out the UR the urge we send
out the energy of
you know what I'm saying like I just
came back and killed in
Tallahassee this is a bum Club in
Worcester and obviously you're sending
out that message and you don't even know
it you don't even know it it's just an
energy that you had you just destroyed a
weekend you just got a standing ovation
on Friday night and here you are
Saturday with the same
material and that's when I started
analyzing
clothes maybe I snort a Coke on Friday
night my
energy yeah that's when you because
you're gonna keep listen I always bombed
on Saturday night when I first start the
headline and at that time people would
say to me don't worry about it it
happens to
everybody and I started believing that
until one day I said you know what I'm
not
everybody that mentality's got to
stop oh you're going to eat it on Friday
night it's all college students and they
don't laugh that mentality has to stop
so I started booking those rooms on
purpose just to overcome that
oh you know this big name
came here on a Thursday and ate a bag of
dicks I he was having a bad night that
night I don't give a about this
this is a whole new night with a whole
new set of rules and you go up
there with that attitude but when you're
young listen I was doing comedy 10 years
now I was I had hair on my balls
I wasn't young but comedy wise I was in
it for 10 years I
remember three times I remember vividly
times I just came back on the road from
Joe Rogan working at a cob
sellout added shows not even cobs I
don't want to say cobs because I used to
die in there too I don't know I don't
know what club I just came back with
Rogan from somewhere and now I go to the
you know to The Comedy Store and I'm
like this is going to be easy
tonight and you die and you get off the
stage and you buy two bags of coke and
you try to figure out what happened and
yeah the inside he wants to say the
audience but at the end one thing about
this podcast I stress with you and I
stress with young Comics that are
getting into this is to we got to blame
ourselves I don't want you to blame the
air conditioner I don't want you to
blame the Boston Celtic game was on till
10:30 and then they wanted to keep it on
with the pool tables that happens
everywhere guys and if you start making
excuses now you're get tangled up in
them go up there and do your best make
sure you write to set down make sure you
write down what you did and be honest
with yourself at night did you really
kill or did you really
bomb don't tell me every night if I
check your notebook that you're
killed I want to see that you know what
my first four minutes were good then
something happened I'll view the tape
and get back to you and then I want to
see a different pen writing in there
with different
handwriting you know why I want to see
that because I didn't do that and I wish
I would have like went back and listen
to your set and commented
yeah I hate looking at
myself the last thing I want to do oh my
God you're looking Chinese and you're
looking like Mr Fuji I got
well no no those Edibles are backfiring
they are but I we both forgot what we
were talking about did you you were
talking about you you were had a tour to
come back to do standup you what you
said you were you around or was
that real what you said you had we you
were gonna go do stand up again Lee have
you lost your mind go bang against the
wall were you 10 times we weren't going
all way that was a fake commercial just
I don't know I felt bad we both forgot
what we were talking about I thought you
were announcing you were coming back no
no no we're talking about doing
spots and eating a bag of dick and
trying to figure out the blame and
knowing that you have percentages going
against you knowing that listen I hate
Sunday nights so what did I do I started
going out on Sunday nights locally I'm
not staying in your town for a
Sunday but if I'm not going to do a spot
in your town I'm definitely
going back to LA to a spot that was my
personal rle to see if everything worked
everything balanced itself
out and you know what I got better as
time went on so don't judge your career
on one set don't say to yourself
I was doing great till then listen
you're gonna have these every
week it's like me two weeks ago I had
pneumonia now I fell and pulled
my ligaments who explains this Joey
not even looking the you know I
get you you think I want to be sitting
on a chair for three days but
this is what happens my brother so where
you I know I'm gonna feel good don't
worry about nothing I I don't I actually
have about since we only talk about the
upcoming week I don't have any upcoming
shows for a little over a week for this
coming week you have just open mic open
mics this week yep that's a show my
world I know I know not opening up for
Rodney Thursday night in shadam you know
I know this but in our world right now
for where we're do we're trying to do
here where are your spots at this week
they'll be at Ralph's at in Wister on
Tuesday and then Wednesday night I'll
probably be at Ricks and wound socket
and the black Zone and Worcester
Thursday there's the uh Hotel part in
Wester you brother you're working it I'm
watching you you know we we're like a
management team here we're trying to
help each other so it's uh it's great to
see you doing this Lee it really is it
inspires the hell out of me not to do a
Mumbo tour with you but just to see you
do your thing you believe
gentlemen he believed I was gonna do a
Mumbo like point that he go what
instrument are you playing are you
dancing like how you going to do the
tour if your legs not heal he just sat
there like like Johnny chines looking at
me I swear to God for a couple minutes
there you look like the dude
from Karate Kid the first one I swear to
God I was hallucinated I don't know what
happened but anyway thank you very much
Lee I'll see you next Tuesday next same
bat Time same bat Channel and that's it
now for a worth my
sponsors
[Music]
listen if you want to get it on you're
gonna have to get it up all right and
blue shw can help you Joey it's a
Tuesday morning why are you starting
with this because listen it's the
holiday season you want to get Santa
Claus ready to give out yum yums listen
for you people who don't know blue Chu
it's an online service that delivers ED
medication right to your door it's got
the same active ingredients as Viagra
Calis and Levitra at a fraction of the
cost how much do I love blue you
tremendously and I'll tell you why it's
easy to sign up it's convenient they
come individually wrapped in a little
package you put it on your wallet by the
time you use it it's probably melted but
who cares you swallow that thing and
within
minutes oh yeah like I said you're like
Santa Claus giving out yum yums I love
blueo because it's easy to get started
sign up at blu.com
and tell one of that licensed medical
providers about what's going on with you
and once you get approved bang you get
your prescription a few days just like
that everything is done online so you
can skip all the waiting in the doctor's
office and stupid questions and
insurance
information da da we don't need that in
our lives and it gets delivered right to
your door nobody knows nothing not even
the mailman blue chw wants to help you
have better sex it's the holiday season
who doesn't want a dick sling dick with
three hands discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and then do it yeah
as a special deal for checking listeners
get ready for this try blue free Joey
it's Tuesday morning don't bust my chop
it's for free Jack blue Che free when
you use promo code Joey Joe y at
checkout just pay the Finn that's $5 for
shipping that's it that's blu.com promo
code Joey to receive your first month
free and nobody knows nothing not even
the mailman all right you ready for this
one Babble I love these people
come stop wasting your time other
language learning apps are basically
just games and teach you nothing if you
want to be fluent in a new language you
got to use Babel b a BB L why number one
you should know another language it just
makes you smarter it makes you more
analytical you learn and Babel's
10-minute lessons will get you speaking
a whole new language in just three weeks
go more
you too could be singing some Ben Benny
morray it's tremendous it's easy to sign
up Babel's tips and tools are accessible
approachable and delivered with
conversation Based Teaching that's
tremendous right there studies even show
that Us in Babel for 15 hours is
equivalent to an entire semester of
college language course here's a special
limited time deal for you guys the check
in listeners we're going to get you
started right now get ready for this 55%
off not half off 55% off your Babel
subscription but only for checking
listeners when you download Babel and
use code Joey Joe y That's 55 who gives
you 55% off babel.com
jooy spelled Babel b a b
b.com Joey rules and restrictions apply
and oh my God look at this guess who
came out for the holidays liquid IV oh
my God guys you gotta taste the
sugar-free Peach forget about it it's
beginning to look a lot like Christmas
you're going to be putting food in your
mouth between the travel and hosting the
family dinner and shopping guess what
you got to keep yourself hydrated
with liquid IV with three times the
electrolytes of leading sports drinks
plus eight vitamins and nutrients for
everyday Wellness no matter when you're
up to it liquid IV will keep you
hydrated liquid IV hydrates twice as
fast as regular water alone twice as
fast liquid IV is now available and
three sugar-free flavors you ready white
peach tremendous green grape tremendous
lemon lime I haven't tried it yet with
no artificial Sweetness in it just got
an amazing flavor without the gross
bitter after taste listen you guys know
me I love liquid Ivy I drink it every
day in the morning to get the party
started to take the maluia juice out of
my head and it works perfectly you know
why it's glutenfree dairy free soyf free
it has no GMOs liquid IV is an amazing
addition to your hydration routine
whatever it may be so do me a favor grab
your liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugarfree inoke nationwide at Costco or
you can get 20% off when you go to
liquid i.com and use promo code Joey
listen this is 20% off liquid IV trust
me this is gold that's 20% off anything
you order when you shop better hydration
today use promo code Joey liquid
i.com enough enough Joey hit me with the
show baby boy